-The president spent the weekend
on an unhinged Twitter rant
after dismissing the rising
threat of white nationalism.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Well, it's another Monday,
and that means once again the
president of the United States
had a quiet, normal weekend
full of hard work
and sober reflection,
and everyone slept well
and woke up refreshed
and optimistic.
And I'm just kidding --
His brain is silly putty,
and we're all doomed.
-President Trump
spends his weekend
lashing out on Twitter.
He hit on everything
from the Mueller probe
to "Saturday Night Live,"
the late Senator John McCain,
and much more.
He tweeted 50 times
this weekend, alone --
30 original tweets,
20 retweets,
bashing Mueller and the Russia
investigation 14 times,
also General Motors, Google,
the United Auto Workers,
Hillary Clinton,
and now today calling Joe Biden
another low-IQ individual.
-I mean, Jesus.
His tweets would make more sense
if they were scribbled on
the wall of a psych ward.
[ Laughter ]
The bottom of every Trump tweet
should have, "like," "retweet,"
or "send me a free Xanax."
This is insane. The president
of the United States
tweeted over 50 times
in one weekend.
He retweeted Fox News
a bunch of times,
attacked John McCain,
General Motors,
Google, Hillary, and China
all in one tweet,
the Paris Climate Accord,
Obama,
the FBI and CIA, Robert Mueller,
"Saturday Night Live,"
Hillary again,
John McCain again,
called on Fox News to bring back
a host he likes,
retweeted Fox News,
attacked Fox News,
the United Auto Workers,
General Motors again,
retweeted multiple
conspiracy theorists,
a bunch of random people,
accused Democrats
of trying to steal the election,
and in the middle of all that,
he also found time to tweet
"Happy St. Patrick's Day!"
[ Laughter, cheers,
and applause ]
Which is appropriate
since he tweets like he's
in the middle of a bar crawl.
[ As Trump, slurring ]
Hey, man, I love you
more than Hillary loves e-mails.
[ Normal voice ] I'm sorry, but
you can't tweet one sane thing
in the middle of
50 insane things.
It's like if you walked by one
of those guys in Times Square
yelling "The end is near!"
and then he turned to you
and calmly said,
"Do you know if there's
a Panera Bread around here?"
[ Laughter ]
Could use a Panera Bread.
I'm a little --
a little peckish.
Trump's behavior this weekend
was so unnerving
that George Conway, the husband
of white house counselor
Kellyanne Conway
and longtime Republican lawyer
in Washington just tweeted,
"His condition
is getting worse."
And, you know, it really says
a lot about the state
of our politics that we all know
who he's talking about.
You don't even need to say
Trump's name anymore.
Everyone will know who you're
talking about if you just tweet,
"He's yelling at the TV again."
Trump's Twitter tirade
was unhinged on its own,
but it's especially unnerving
that he chose to spend his time
attacking everyone
from "Saturday Night Live"
to John McCain just days
after the horrific shootings
at two mosques in New Zealand.
The gunman was a white
nationalist
who targeted Muslims
and was steeped in a culture
of online extremism.
And, yet, when Trump
was asked on Friday
about the rising threat
of white nationalism
around the world,
he shrugged it off.
-Do you see today
white nationalism
as a rising threat
around the world?
-I don't really. I think it's
a, uh, small group of people
that have very, very
serious problems.
-First of all,
a small group of people
that have very serious problems
isn't an answer to the question,
"Is white nationalism a threat?"
If anything, it's answer
to the question,
"Who still works
at the White House?"
[ Laughter ]
Second, of course you
don't see it as a threat.
You called on a ban for Muslims
coming to the U.S.,
and you're trying to
build a wall to keep out
Mexican asylum seekers.
Asking Trump if he sees
white nationalism as a threat
is like asking Joe Camel if
he sees tobacco as a threat.
[ Gruff voice ] Well, only if
you're threatened by bold flavor
and satisfaction.
[ Laughter ]
In fact, instead of addressing
the rising threat
of white nationalism,
Trump spent part of his
deranged Twitter bender
over the weekend defending
Fox News host Jeanine Pirro
and Tucker Carlson
who were under fire
for making racist
and Islamophobic remarks.
-Trump tweeting in defense
of his friend,
"Bring back Judge Jeanine Pirro.
The radical left Democrats
working closely with
their beloved partner,
the fake news media,
is using every trick in the book
to silence a majority
of our country.
They have all-out campaigns
against Fox News hosts
who are doing too well."
-"The losers all want what you
have, don't give it to them.
Be strong and prosper.
Be weak and die. Stay true."
-"Keep fighting for Tucker and
fight hard for Judge Jeanine.
Your competitors are jealous.
They all want what you've got,
number one."
-The president
of the United States
is an angry grandpa
who spends his time
yelling at the TV to bring back
his favorite shows.
God forbid they ever cancel
"Pawn Stars"
or he'll have a full-on
meltdown.
[ As Trump ] Bring back Chumlee,
or I'll launch a nuke!
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Also,
what do you mean,
"Be strong and prosper,
be weak and die"?
You sound like you're about
to ring in
the 74th annual "Hunger Games."
[ Laughter ]
Also, also...
[ Applause ]
Also...
remember when Trump said
he didn't have time to watch TV
because he's too busy reading?
In case you forgot,
he told reporters,
and this is a real quote,
"I don't get to watch
much television
primarily because of documents.
I'm reading documents a lot."
[ Laughter ]
First of all, you watch
plenty of television.
You got mad at a rerun
of "SNL" this weekend --
A rerun.
You watch more "SNL"
than Lorne Michaels,
and that's not a joke.
I have been next to Lorne
when a sketch starts bombing,
and that man straight-up
leaves the room.
Second,
let's make something clear --
no one who actually reads
documents ever says,
"I'm too busy reading
documents."
That's something a lawyer
in a porno says
in the first 30 seconds
of a scene
where you're supposed to think,
"Oh, maybe
they're not going to do it.
I hope I didn't rent a porno
that's just law stuff.
Also, why did I rent a porno?
Oh, right, to support
a local business.
Don't you quit, Frank.
I know you're going to
outlast the Internet."
[ Laughter ]
Trump wants us all to think
he spends his free time
in the study smoking a pipe,
poring over stacks of papers.
"Mr. President, we need you
to come to your bedroom
and watch TV."
[ As Trump ] Oh, not now, I pray
you leave me to my documents."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] So, the
president of the United States
decided to spend his weekend
defending Jeanine Pirro
and Tucker Carlson -- in fact,
Pirro was specifically
criticized for making
Islamophobic remarks
about Minnesota Congresswoman
Ilhan Omar earlier this month.
The remarks were so heinous,
even Fox News condemned them
and pulled her off the air.
-Omar wears a hijab,
which according to
the Qur'an 33:59,
tells women to cover
so they won't get molested.
Is her adherence to
this Islamic doctrine
indicative of her adherence
to Sharia Law,
which in itself is antithetical
to the United States
Constitution?
-The only thing worse than
saying something that offensive
is saying it that loud.
Why does she always talk like
she has a bad connection?
"I said, 'How are things
at college?'"!
[ Laughter ]
You know, when you say
something bigoted,
you're supposed to whisper it
in private, right?
Jeanine Pirro style would say,
[ Whispers ]
"You know who I don't like?
[ Loudly ] Muslims!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Then there's Tucker Carlson,
the bad guy from every
John Hughes movie.
It was reported that he made a
series of racist, misogynist,
and homophobic comments
on a radio show in the 2000s
hosted by a guy named
Bubba the Love Sponge.
And let me just say,
I was so confused to hear
that Tucker Carlson
went on a show hosted by someone
named Bubba the Love Sponge
that I made the same face
Tucker Carlson makes
every night on his show.
[ Laughter ]
Look at him. He always
looks like he's 30 seconds
into an allergic reaction.
[ Laughter ]
"Were there nuts
in this muffin?"
He looks like he's
three quarters of the way
to Rudy Giuliani.
[ Laughter ]
Now, anyone who has paid
any attention to politics at all
knows that Trump has spent years
as a businessman, candidate,
and president openly spouting
anti-Muslim bigotry,
yet Trump's aides have been
trying to memory hole
his long history of racism
and Islamophobia,
like his acting Chief of Staff
Mick Mulvaney.
Mulvaney said on Sunday
that he would like us all
to ignore the things
that Trump says
and focus instead
on what he does.
-As a candidate, the president
called for a ban on all Muslims
entering the United States.
He said Islam hates us.
This kind of language in the
past leads to these questions
of why isn't the president now
directly using that megaphone
to condemn it?
-Take the -- take the words
and put them one category
and take the actions
and put them in another.
-Oh, he's the president,
but we have to separate
the words from the actions
like we're taking out
the [bleep] recycling?
Word. Action.
Word.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Word, but it's still got a lot
of spaghetti in it, so action."
And I'm sorry, but his
only actions are words.
Other than Twitter,
what else does he do?
You won't let us watch him golf,
even though if you did,
it would be higher rated
than the Super Bowl.
I mean, I would watch.
Because there's so much
that I want to know.
Is he actually good,
or is he terrible, and everyone
pretends that he's good?
I know he cheats, but how?
Is he good at it,
or is he super obvious?
Does he make a weird noise
when he swings, and if so,
is it the same noise, or does
it change based on the club?
Seriously, televise
his next golf game,
sell it on pay-per-view, and
build your wall with that money.
[ Laughter, cheers,
and applause ]
And I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, but you don't get
to put Trump's words
in a different category
unless that category
is signs you might be having
a stroke.
-Every single car out there,
even the really
"expenses" ones...
Controlled by large "derners"...
10,000 known or "suspested"
gang members.
-Mulvaney then went on to
claim that despite Trump's
long established history
of anti-Muslim bigotry,
Trump, himself,
was not Islamophobic.
-I hear what folks say,
"Oh, Donald Trump said this
during the campaign."
Look at what we've done
while we've been here.
And I don't think anybody
could say
that the president's
anti-Muslim.
-Well, let me try --
The president is anti-Muslim.
Yep, that was not hard at all.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was easy to say.
Certainly wasn't as hard
as saying "suspested."
[ Laughter ]
You know, you're not very bright
for someone who looks like
grown-up Sherman.
[ Laughter ]
Trump has spent his entire
political career
trafficking anti-Muslim bigotry,
and now he's defending people
who've done the same.
Of course, these guys
have to stick together
because they are a --
-Small group of people
that have very, very serious
problems.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪